the name is Connery Chantal
we all know that actors can part the Red
Sea and tear down temples with our bare
hands move bridges and even push back
earthquakes but we'd all be nothing
without the help of the men and women
with the real power the creators of
special visual effects and the nominees
for achievement in that field are
predator Joel henyk Robert M Greenberg
Richard Greenberg and Stan Winston
in a space Dennis Muren William George
Harley Jessup and canna Smith and the
winner is our Dennis Muren William
George
Harley Jessica Kenneth Smith for inner
space
this is a big thrill we really like to
thank the Academy
Joe Donnie for doing his great direction
Mike Finnell course Steven Speilberg
rabo teen my wife Zahra also thanks to
Ned Gorman Ed Hirsch in the stage
department he's so young Barbara Alfonso
Larry tan and the island model makers
and also my family and my friends thanks
to John Fante and all the cameramen -
Richard van der went to John Knoll my
wife Ann thanks to Don Clark peg hunter
James Lynn and all those books at
Industrial Light & Magic thank you very
much thanks
during the course of the evening we will
be showing you the scenes from the five
films nominated for Best Picture these
are the cream of the crop our first
nominated picture is the story of a
married man who has a business meeting
with a beautiful girl it turns into a
one-night stand she wants another night
so she kidnaps his child
tries to kill his wife and attacks him
with a knife that was to me all the time
it's called fatal attraction
I just think it's wonderful that we can
do this together one I'm glad we got
something I'm certainly glad you can
make it tonight would be having an Oscar
first this evening on behalf of Glenn
and this lady is really do so we're
gonna move right on with the nominations
it's a good idea